EDDIE BEARNOT: Direct Fresh
is Bangladesh's first premium
online grocery store.
I think our biggest challenge
is getting customers online.
E-commerce is brand
new to Bangladesh,
and so shoppers aren't
accustomed to buying
anything online, especially not
their groceries, where they're
used to going into a store and
seeing and feeling the objects.
So there's a lot of education
that we've had to do.
But that's one of our
biggest challenges.
SAM BRETZFIELD:
Another challenge
would be the online payment
gateway here in Bangladesh.
It's a very convoluted process,
not very user friendly,
which means that in
some cases, customers
have to go literally to two
to three different pages
in order to just check out.
So we've overcome that really
by having a handheld credit card
machine where our customers are
able to swipe their cards when
their food is delivered.
MISHAL KARIM: We've also done
a lot of work with our website,
studying analytics
and user experience.
We now feel we can
take this model
and drop it in other cities.
And we've identified Bangkok,
Goa, the UK as the next three
cities that we're
going to go after.